now several dozen folks we've counted
have gathered out here and more i'm told
are expected throughout the rest of the
evening now we spoke today with the
executive director of battle born
progress and magnus and she tells me
that this rally was very organic after
the u.s supreme court's decision was
announced she says residents here in
southern nevada were torn and just upset
and really needed a voice this rally is
all about that now it's open to the
public
for residents to basically come out here
and speak their minds now in this group
we found jerry burton executive director
with nevada now and thank you so much
for joining us out here today and just
tell me a little bit about what this
rally means for all the people out here
well we had planned on having a press
conference today and then some actions
all next week but people kept calling us
and they needed a place to come and you
know frankly mourn
so we set it up and we've been getting
all the different progressive groups in
town and a lot of people new people that
just want to
tell what a sad day this is for them
so many people out here just trying to
voice their opinions thank you so much
for your time we also got the chance to
speak earlier today with lieutenant
governor via zoom and this is what she
had to say for all nevadans
i think it's important to
uh make sure that uh nevadans are paying
attention because while we do have some
embedded protections for our state
uh this is uh one step of what i feel is
going to be
many as you mentioned for other things
to come
back out here live we know nevada is a
pro-choice state and that's according to
this organization that is basically what
is holding them together during this
time a very difficult time they say
for women's rights we are live in
downtown christian gossip is live local
now